[Musique]
et là nous avons fait ça quand même pas
léguer un trophée samedi à sa sauce
valises aux grands faire bien avec moi
mais se raconter à mes parents je domine
ou high domino il rappelé
[Musique]
mais je vous la pose un petit bout de
blanc vous allez les stomisés ça mon nom
est allé bouffer tout bouge pas en garde
et nous reprendrons pas le droit
[Musique]
11 k o et camions par louis van gaal et
moi sommes partis car tu as yade
[Musique]
mais grimper à tiques polka oui mon père
a toujours été dans une famille coupable
car il n'a rien pas faire les esclaves
venus de madagascar bateau n'avait plein
d'esclaves comme lui les boudins de
chine de l'afrique
c'est pour ça que tous les mélanges et
la réunion car chinois mal bord d'un
radeau gré chacun dans les autres usines
autres religions de cultures et la forme
le mixage réunionnais amis qui si tout
ce monde de la photo ça c'est la bonne
tactique automne même ceux de maman et
30 dalons dimanche notre affaire tefere
pique nique nous tout l'été réunis ben
dhia du tpir que manger un peu tes
jouets domino n'atterrit carte bonne
arme a été jouée quatre doc
côté jeux la rue a par contre votre
grand père soja affaire peut faire
manger tu es le meilleur pour faire
engueuler saucisses à l'ambassade de
france
[Musique]
à l'eau des grands
greg on a dit non bâti chanteuse
activités donnent la main quand nous
tout est filmé bien manger tati ginette
et ati jacqueline dans le katanga
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous
m
[Musique]
et
que de bons souvenirs nami telle
occasion
oui bah moi me et bien joué qu'à y en
ait qui je n'y ai mes patries pas
prendre à moi car on annonce à une maman
oui ça arrive eric béroud de manas
écoles ah oui c'est vrai la raison on a
parfois ses jours dimanche et effet pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
inquiet je t'ai pas dit quand je
découvre un billet valise qui
appartenait à mon grand père m'a
grandement maastricht et l'esclavagé
comment ils ont vécu
mais je longtemps la musique
bref c'était passionnant de quoi bois
gel avec moi je me suis blessé a
toujours affirmé rila nom m'a quand même
à bien ma prius il le bienfait des
plantes médicinales
ah bah tiens voilà que vera flora tu
peux me passer le sécateur s'il te plaît
merci
tu as bien de la chance que tagro meert
et raconter tout ça tu te rends compte
qu'on a d'être isr dont le jardin tu
sais ma grand mère elle aime bien
raconter des histoires entendre comme
star à une tige en grands grands mercan
tu marchais maintien va du romarin
en tout cas nous raconte tout ça notre
tease enfants à nos enfants
il faut que nous transmettre notre
tradition il faut que nous gardions
d'entités réunionnaise
alors qu'avec
[Musique]